hey there and welcome to the motion
science video podcast my name is Cameron
and today we're going to talk about as a
motion designer do you need to
understand design
[Music]
hey there and like I said welcome to the
podcast I'm Cameron this is motion
science and I'm glad to have you with me
here today because in today's video we
are talking about if you need to know
design ok and the short answer is plain
and simple yes ok now there's gonna be
people who disagree with me who say well
I don't need no design I'm a motion guy
and I'm good with that and that's fine
and dandy for you but honestly if you
want to be super successful as a motion
designer you need to understand design
ok
the only time you don't need to
understand design is if you're in like a
studio environment like a major studio
pipeline and in that pipeline you have
one single job and that one single job
could be maybe you're a camera operator
right a virtual camera operator or maybe
you texture or maybe you're a lighting
technician right or you're a rigger or
you know strictly a character animator
whatever it is you're working for a
major studio and you have one single job
and that's it right that's the only time
you don't really need to understand
design in my opinion because any other
time whether you're working for a studio
like a production studio or an agency or
direct to client or for any other type
of client you need to understand design
so that your work doesn't look like crap
right and then plain and simple you
don't want your work your work to look
like crap and I see it all day long
especially on social media channels
right now ok I'm not here to bash on
anybody and say don't go follow this guy
because his work sucks but it's a truth
that no one's talking about is that all
day long with social media I see people
who are animating things like dynamics
right like we've got fluids flying out
of something or fluids flying over a
letter or a piece of tape or something's
bouncing and it's great that you can do
that
but in typically the animations awesome
but the design sucks right and you're
never gonna get hired in the real world
by any good client if you don't have an
eye for something right and like it like
unless I said like that clients hiring
you just to do one task of animating so
I see it a lot like I said I see
different online education being taught
where it's like click this button you
will learn how to be a great animator
but at the same time you put out the
work and you've made something you've
animated it looks great but it looks
great in the animation terms not in it's
not pleasing to the eye okay so if I am
really good at let's say I can rig a
character and I can make a walk cycle
really look good if my character does
not look good or my scene doesn't look
good in the composition is not looking
correct and I don't understand the rule
of thirds and I don't understand color
palettes and I don't understand what
shape is or line bottom line you're not
going to get hired to do motion graphics
to do motion design as a professional
right maybe a client will come along and
say hey you know can you animate this
this artwork that's already done and
that's great and maybe you can animate
it but if you still don't understand why
that artwork looks great what
compositionally about that is working so
well then you're I'm guessing your
animations still gonna suck right
because you don't understand that things
should be flowing certain ways our eye
should be pointed certain ways and that
that relates to animation right because
you understand what good design is so if
you don't understand that you're not
going to get hired to do this work that
that you want to do so bad and you're
always just kind of have it as a hobby
right and that's great if you want to
keep it as a hobby and just kind of play
around that that's great but if you want
to do this professionally and you want
to get paid to do this you need to
understand
what good design is and some of the
rules about it right so my advice to you
is keep honing your animation skills but
at the same time you need to start
understanding what design is and that
doesn't mean that you have to go hire
someone like me and and take a motion
science course or you have to go hire
this guy over here and take his design
course and be a graphic designer you
don't have to do that right now what you
can do right now or some simple steps
those are steps like you could just look
at work that inspires you and for all of
us we're all attracted to different
types of creative motion design and so
you just need to find something that
inspires you and then I want you to take
that piece and I want you to break it
down okay now if this is like a two or
three-minute title sequence don't take
the entire title sequence and break it
down bit by bit just take like 30
seconds of it or 15 seconds of it a part
that really stands out to you and then
study that and study what about that is
speaking to you visually what about that
now if it's you know part of its the
motion and the animation that's great
you know maybe you already understand
what that is but then start looking at
how things move and why they're moving
and what other parts of that that image
or that title sequence or that piece
online is speaking to you is it the
colors and if it is the colors what
about the colors are working so why are
they complementing each other is it is
it the overall shapes of the design of
whatever's in that piece is it is it the
is it repetition that's happening what
about is it texture these are all
elements of great design so what you can
do right now is just take those pieces
break them down study them and and start
to understand why why they work right
what about them works now that's how I
learned
I never went through a traditional art
school I never went through a
traditional art program I can't draw or
the crap but I have I've taken the time
over the years and I've really studied a
lot of great motion design and I
continue to study it to improve my
skills and I continued to study
designers that speak
to me and I learn from what they do and
I bring it into my own style and my own
methods and I'm able to implement a
strong motion design piece because I do
understand design with the motion right
we are motion designers now some of you
will call us motion graphic artists or
motion graphic designers but the word
graphic is in there the word designer is
in there for a reason okay so I just
encourage you to get out there and start
learning parts of motion design the
design side of it because it is going to
make you a better motion designer in the
long run
so hopefully that this helps you out
helps you understand where you need to
go to get better as a motion designer I
invite you to check out motion science
TV we have lots of great courses we have
lots of amazing memberships to help you
become the best motions designer that
you can be until next time I am Cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]